[Music]
[Music]
good morning to you it's seven o'clock
you're watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster thousands of
people have enjoyed a first night inside
pubs and restaurants
but it could lead to tears with reports
of governments considering
localized restrictions with the indian
variant threatening more
lockdown easing next month plus could a
mass
vaccination program on 200 islands
secure
a summer getaway we'll talk to the
environment secretary
george eustis in a few minutes also for
you this morning the former love island
star turned
mental health advisor to the government
dr alex george is here
to share about his new book on the many
ways we can look after our own
well-being
plus if your four-legged friend has
piled on the pounds during lockdown
we'll hear how they could get back in
shape and become a star
of the canine games it's tuesday
the 18th of may happy mondays a first
taste of freedom as indoor hospitality
resumes
but with fears of localized lockdowns if
the indian covid variant
spreads out of control i don't know what
to expect
because the new variant on the loom
everything's kind of up in the air
[Music]
airstrikes have dawn on gaza city as
president biden calls for a ceasefire
after eight days of violence between
israel and palestinian militants
structural anomalies excavation work to
begin at a cafe where police are
searching for a missing girl
linked to the serial killer fred west
a root and branch review plans to treble
tree planting in england over the next
three years to tackle the effects of
climate change
good morning our cool and changeable
weather continues
sunny smiles and scattered showers some
of which could be heavy
slow moving with a risk of heal and
thunder
very good morning to you now while
thousands across many parts of england
scotland and wales
enjoyed a first taste of freedom in
months as indoor hospitality reopened
there is
increasing concern that localized
restrictions could be imposed
unless the indian variant of kovid 19 is
brought under control
86 local authorities have reported
outbreaks of the new strain threatening
the next stage of lockdown easing on the
21st of june
becky johnson reports cheers
finally being allowed to have a night
out inside a pub
was caused for celebration
as restaurants prepared to give
customers a taste of what they'd be
missing
these diners in birmingham felt they'd
earned their newfound freedom
we've been so good you know we've obeyed
everything
and now we've all been second vaccinated
and it's just so fabulous
[Music]
it was opening night for theaters able
to welcome back
audiences after months of uncertainty
the fact that venues like this can
can host nights for people to get out
and performing again it's just so
exciting
for us performers and for people as well
i feel like it's really missed to see
live music
and cinemas reopened too going to see a
film with friends never felt like such a
treat
but a rise in cases of the indian
variant is causing concern
at a time when business owners were
expecting to feel more optimistic
about the months ahead to be honest with
you i don't know what to expect
because the new variant on the loom
everything's kind of up in the air
customers you'll get some confident
customers that have had their vaccine
that are confident to come back out
and you'll have those that are quite
reluctant as they don't know
how transmissible or how dangerous the
new variant is
allowing indoor mixing at a time when a
new variant is spreading is seen
by many as a risk and scientists will be
watching closely over the coming days
and weeks to see what impacts it has
[Music]
one thing we've all learned is nothing
is certain and for now
people are determined to celebrate the
freedoms they
have becky johnson sky news in
birmingham
president biden has spoken to the
israeli prime minister and urged
both sides in the middle east conflict
to agree a ceasefire
have been further air strikes in gaza
overnight as well as an exchange of
rocket and artillery fire across the
border
between lebanon and israel for the two
million people who live in gaza life has
become
very difficult in the last week as they
deal with air strikes
and power cuts mark stone reports from
jerusalem
this is the view from the keek family
home
next door the hadidis once lived a
family now without a mother
and four of her sons the keeks somehow
survived three generations and holding
together
just
the sound is the israeli drones they've
been low overhead through the day
hitting targets across the strip
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mohammed kik is 25 the weight of one
family's struggle
is on him
then there is the other generation his
daughters
how do you explain to them why their
neighbors their friends are dead
there is no innocence in gaza
there is water here but it no longer
comes out of the taps
the bombing has damaged the mains pipes
it's taken out the electricity supply
too
it's down to a maximum of two hours a
day now and there is little fuel for the
generators
[Music]
this is islam muhammad's sister so bad
so
scary
so bad
[Music]
the un run schools are a focal point
classrooms are now bedrooms for the many
hundreds of families whose houses are
destroyed
and the thousands more who are too
frightened to be home
the families here tell us there has been
an air strike every five minutes
for a population locked in and already
70
dependent on aid and food this is
devastating
but with footage like this as evidence
of what they say are as precise strikes
as possible
the israeli military claim they have
killed 130 palestinian militants
this they say is the targeting of a
small hamas submarine
and this was for israel a prize they
claimed they killed a top commander
hussain abu habid was for 15 years a
leader within the palestinian islamic
jihad yet
despite all this there is no sign a weak
on that either side is prepared to stop
not even for aid to get in israel calls
this proportionate
and civilian deaths regrettable hamas
says
it is the defender of the palestinian
people the cycle goes on
mark stone sky news in jerusalem
well alex rossi is in jerusalem for us
this morning i mean
do you think the calls from president
biden alex are falling on deaf ears at
the moment
i think it is at this stage quite
difficult to read
exactly what that means from president
biden
uh he has spoken with uh
netanyahu a few times since this
conflict
began but this is the first time that he
has
expressed support for a ceasefire and
that is very carefully worded
he stopped short of calling for an
immediate ceasefire
and there are a number of ways of
reading that one is perhaps he doesn't
want to be defied by benjamin netanyahu
of course israel is a close ally to call
for an immediate ceasefire
and then for it to be ignored would be
devastating
but perhaps more likely he's giving the
israeli military
the israeli state a bit more time to
achieve their tactical
objectives inside gaza it may be that we
are
as a result of this phone call entering
a new phase perhaps
a winding down phase where the mediation
will be ramped up and towards the end of
the week you will get a ceasefire
but that perhaps is hopeful if you
listen
to what benjamin netanyahu is saying if
you
listen to all of the stuff on the
surface
well it doesn't appear to be heading in
that direction at all he
has said it will take some time and the
operations
over gaza will continue now israeli
air force struck many targets in gaza
overnight attacking what they call in
defense circles
the metro system this is the underground
network of tunnels which hamas
and other palestinian militant groups
use to move their fighters around
and launch rockets sirens are once again
ringing out over southern israel in the
early hours of this morning
and throughout the morning as more
rockets are being launched but the
number of rockets
being launched is fewer and the distance
that they are traveling
is also less which suggests uh that
certainly on the hamas side they want to
try and de-escalate
this and head towards a ceasefire that
of course could change
dramatically we heard overnight hamas
giving
a warning to the israelis that if they
continue to attack high-rise
buildings they will once again launch
rockets towards central israel
and tel aviv which again would ramp up
the escalation massively
and continue this cycle of violence
we're not at the end yet
it could continue for some time remember
of course in 2014
it went on for nearly seven weeks but
the hope is of course
that the mediation will work and we will
head towards a ceasefire towards the end
of the week but we're not at that point
yet
okay alex thank you
some breaking news this morning and the
unemployment figures for the three
months to february
have just been released so let's get all
the details from our business
correspondent paul kelso what do they
tell us paul
good morning stephen they tell us there
are some glimmers of hope
in the employment market after a
dreadful 14
months we saw many so many businesses
reopening in doors yesterday didn't we
that so many people
returning to work for the first time and
that's borne out
a little by these numbers the employment
rate for the three months
to february was 4.8 the unemployment
rate forgive me
was 4.8 that is 0.3
lower than in the previous quarter so
fewer people
unemployed there's also some slightly
more uh
recent data that the office for national
statistics have provided on the number
of people on payrolls
in april that is people receiving a
paycheck
through the taxation system there are
nearly a hundred thousand more people
on payrolls in april than there were in
march thanks the ons say and perhaps it
it's obvious isn't it lockdown began to
ease and they say a lot of those
jobs were in the hospitality and
entertainment sectors where
work could begin to return to something
like normal now the office for national
statistics so these numbers
uh show the employment market is stable
with signs of recovery which is
precisely what the chancellor will have
been wanting to hear
from these numbers we know the furlough
scheme which has been propping up the
whole labor market for so long
it's going to start to taper off
businesses are going to start to have to
pay towards that
at the end of june it will end entirely
in september now the very strong message
from businesses
i was talking to yesterday particularly
in hospitality was that if that june
21st next step in the lockdown in the
roadmap doesn't happen they want
that support extended so we're in the
teeth of the crucial part of this big
economic gamble
removing the furlough as jobs return
will
it save people from ending up on the
dolque
okay paul thank you well let's get more
now the warnings around the spread of
the new variant
of covid19 the indian variant let's talk
to the environment secretary george
justice good to see you this morning
look a lot of people were celebrating
last night and
understandably so it does raise concerns
though doesn't it to be
to be reopening things up to be opening
society and opening
the economy at a time when we know this
pretty dangerous variant
is actually spreading in the country
well look that is why we are taking
things one step at a time
uh taking things cautiously if you like
um we've
done the next stage of reopening the
overall prevalence of the virus is now
very low in this country there are these
hot spots particularly around places
like
bolton where the variant that was first
discovered
in india has been detected i know that
matt hancock said that we've done some
research into that variant the vaccine
does seem to be effective against it but
it does seem to have a higher
transmission rate and the
greatest defense we've really got is to
ensure that people continue
to get their vaccinations that we roll
out that program that people in those
areas who might have
chosen not to get the vaccine so far do
now get it
yeah i mean vaccine hesitancy actually
within that area and amongst
uh black and ethnic minority communities
does seem to be pretty high at the
moment i think the uptake in
in in one particular area affected by
this variant is 37
which is just not good enough is it how
how do you begin to really now tackle
that hesitancy issue
well we've been doing a lot in recent
months to get those communities who are
a bit more
hesitant to engage with this program to
have the vaccine i think maybe in those
areas when they
see the resurgence of the virus it may
prompt them to think actually
this is serious the vaccine is effective
it is
preventing the spread of this in other
areas so now let's
uh now let's get it and we we just need
to keep redoubling our efforts in some
of those hard-to-reach communities
to get them to see that uh having the
vaccine for all of us is the best way
out of this terrible pandemic
do we need more sort of voices from the
these affected communities
to come up and speak do we think well a
lot of work is being done
in those communities and it has been you
know quite effective in getting uptake
but yes there are still pockets where
uptake is low and we
there's no shortcut to this we've just
got to to redouble our efforts to get uh
community leaders uh faith leaders and
some of those bame communities
uh to really encourage people to come
forward and have the vaccine
where are we in terms of the whole
vaccine process i know it's gone very
well for the age groups that have been
that have been targeted so far but this
highlights doesn't it need to get this
process
sped up to an extent well we've been
running it at a phenomenal
rate to be honest uh we we now have
close to 70 percent
of the population have had uh their
first job
approaching now i think 40 percent have
even had their second job
we've uh reduced now the time scale
between those two from 12 weeks
initially now down to eight weeks so
that we can speed up the roll out of
that
second jab because we think that with
this new variant discovered
first in india that there is uh
additional protection if you like from
that uh
second uh second job and the second jab
becomes more important so
we're trying to condense those scales
and get the second jabs out as soon as
we can
i was talking to quarter quarten
yesterday and he was saying
that it is he thinks still very likely
that
the next stage of of lockdown easing
with the full lifting of everything
on june 21st could still go ahead i mean
are you as confident as the business
secretary well i we want it to go ahead
uh there's a whole plan about it
of course but we cannot rule anything
out and and that is why the prime
minister said we will take this a step
at a time
as we have one set of easements and just
yesterday we've
had a further set of easements opened
more parts of the economy
we need to see how that beds down over
the next two to three weeks
and then shortly before the 21st of june
we'll be in a position to assess
whether we can go to that next stage we
want to do that that's always been the
plan
we want each step to be an irreversible
step but we can never rule out that
there may have to be a delay i mean
with that in mind is the government
actively looking at
you know opening fully opening on the
21st whilst imposing
if necessary local restrictions on areas
that are still struggling
is that an option that would be an
option and we cannot um
rule anything out obviously at this
stage but our preferred
um our preferred outcome is that we
really double down
and get the vaccination rates up in
those areas that are seeing
uh these problems so that we can give
them the immunity that they need to this
virus
and then we won't have to have any such
local lockdowns now
again talking to quasi quatering
yesterday he wasn't particularly in
favor of the idea that certainly in
places like
bolton and blackburn they seem to be
should we say bending the rules a little
bit
on who can be getting vaccinated finding
a reason to vaccinate anyone who wants
to come forward
what's your view on that because if that
is going to tackle the problem and these
are
worrying hot spots don't we just need to
get as many people
jabbed up as possible well we do need to
get as many um
jabbed as possible but also the the
advice that we have from the joint
committee
on vaccinations who advise us on this is
that if you
divert effort to vaccinating very young
cohorts people in say their 20s
at the expense of vaccinating those in
their 30s or 40s
if they've got you are risking but if
they've got the supplies if they've
locally got the supplies
it's not necessarily a bad thing is it
well i mean there will be
lots of already cases where if they've
got supplies and they can do it then
they will push people through
faster but to have a conscious decision
to say vaccinate the whole population in
those areas
uh when actually there are still many
people in the cohorts of
you know 35 and above who've maybe not
had the vaccine
the right thing to do is to get those
over the age of 35 to have the vaccine
since it's the older you are the more at
risk you are i'm just in tree you say 35
my understanding is it's currently 36 at
the moment
is it dropping down to 30. it's dropping
it's dropping regularly i think will it
not today
uh i don't think it'll drop today but
it's uh and you know but i i don't know
exactly what the update of the break
but it's moving all i'd say is on a
almost a daily basis moving down
the age range yeah look can we talk
about brexit a little bit i mean
we have to be very careful don't we
about brexit now that with
we you know we've we've gone past all
these hurdles
we have to be very careful don't we that
any trade deals that we're now working
on do not
negatively impact groups in the uk i
mean particularly
hugely important groups like the british
farming sector
well and that's always the case in all
trade agreements um
you you go into these we we think
there's great opportunities
we're very keen for instance to pursue
trade agreements with uh
australia and also with the united
states and uh with other countries uh
as well and um but always in any trade
agreement yes there's a balance to be
struck between
uh you know your commercial interests
and your your desire to open up free
markets
is there a danger then with for example
australia if there was a free trade deal
that would potentially negatively impact
the british farming sector wouldn't it
well there are huge amounts of things
that a country like australia produces
that are
currently subject to tariffs because
that's what we had in the european union
but we're actually we're not even a
producer and we can um
offer them terror free access in those
areas everything from nectarines to
almond nuts where they're a big producer
and also of course wine
the air what about the areas where we
are a producer well it's a
standard thing in any trade agreement
that where you have what are called
sensitive sectors that's
uh particular areas where there might be
economic impacts to having a trade
agreement well there are
well-established ways to to manage that
where you can have
what's called a tariff rate quota as if
you like a tariff-free envelope and a
set volume so there's ways of uh dealing
with all of these things
but is it is it right that the
international trade secretary is pushing
for a zero tariff uh
approach with australia across the board
well look
i'm not going to get into uh you know
discussions that are going on in
government about individual trade
agreements no you're not happy though
are you oh no
in any discussion on any part of
government policy and trade agreements
are no exception there's a
there's a discussion and there's a
consensus and at the moment there's a
very clear consensus in government that
we want to do
a trade agreement with countries like
australia but obviously on the right
terms
is it fair to say then that you've had
some robust discussions as reported in
the ft
today i have uh very good discussions
with all of my cabinet colleagues on
all issues where we've got a shared
agenda
i think the smile says it all is that
that's for this affair
no i mean of course um in any um
discussion on any part of
government policy there will be uh
issues where different government
departments have a
uh shared interest and um you know we we
obviously have a discussion in order to
establish a consensus
okay um looking post pandemic
how do we start to to properly rebuild
the economy it's going to take a lot of
work
how do we rebuild the economy and
rebuild it greener well
um we've been setting out today and i'm
doing a big speech later today about
nature and the environment we want to
put a much bigger focus on nature so we
are announcing a
strategy on peat which will include a
ban on the sale and use of
horticultural peat in garden centers and
a really big ambition to treble the
amount of
trees that we plant okay look minister
it's good to talk to you this morning
thank you thank you very much indeed
okay
also in the headlines this morning
president biden has said the united
states will donate a further 20 million
doses
of coronavirus vaccines to the rest of
the world for the first time
president biden will give away
injections previously destined for
domestic use scientists say they've
developed a way of using artificial
intelligence to predict the
possible risk of someone having a heart
attack researchers in the united states
claim the machine can use
time and weather patterns even to report
when a cardiac arrest is more likely
cancer charities say trans and
non-binary people need to be encouraged
to come forward for cervical checks
they say many patients face barriers
including the fact that transgender men
or
non-binary people assigned female at
birth are less likely to be invited
to screening appointments
teaching unions say staff should not be
responsible for running coronavirus
track and trace systems in school the
naht school leaders union a warning that
more staff could leave the profession
after some heads of school spent more
than a hundred hours identifying
positive cases
now if you live anywhere but london
you've probably seen these scattered
about the roads but now an official
trial of e-scooter rentals is going to
be held in london it's the first time
they've been legally allowed on the
capitals roads and cycle paths
they'll have a maximum speed of 12 and a
half miles
an hour believe you may they get
everywhere
the pop star ariana grande has confirmed
she's got married
pretty much in secret the 27 year old
and her husband
dalton gomez are reported to have had
what was described as a tiny
and intimate ceremony with just 20
people
in california
now today marks 15 years since the death
of kian prince the young queen's park
rangers player who was stabbed trying to
break up a fight
outside his school well now advanced
technology has created an avatar of
what would be a 30 year old now that he
could have been if he'd really
gone on to play in the top leagues
highlighting the
impact they hope of knife crime jemima
walker reports
aged 15 kyan's dreams of becoming a
professional football player was
snatched away
now thanks to deep fake technology input
from
scientists and his family he's been
re-signed by his former club
and will make his debut as a fifa player
cayenne's father hopes the image of his
son fulfilling his
childhood dream will inspire vulnerable
young people
a young black boy whose life was taken
too early and it's demonstrated to all
the young people who love playing fifa
that young people with knives in their
hands
is creating this where you are
robbing your community robbing your
your country robbing your society from
seeing
people that look like yourself reach
their destiny
seeing them achieve their goals
since his son was fatally stabbed after
intervening in a fight
dr prince has dedicated his life to
combating knife crime
through the cayenne prince foundation he
says there needs to be more investment
in
early preventative measures after kyan
died the law was changed to increase the
age
you could buy a knife from 16 to 18.
but 15 years on the issue of knife crime
still persists and in many cases it's
getting worse so what role do clubs like
this play in tackling it
get a student who might struggle be at
school put them in a football ground
suddenly it's a
completely different environment and
they're they're mesmerized by it and
this is the you know the dream come true
we always tell our young players coming
through you know a lot of you
you may not make it as a professional
football player that doesn't mean one
you can't make a living in football or
two
you can't make a decent living in
something else because we'll make sure
you have some skill sets when you leave
here that no matter what you decide to
do
you can be successful in doing that
kyan's killer could soon be released
from prison
first kyan's father wants to meet him
let's support and help the guy to be
able to make the change
so he doesn't continue to cycle there's
no point us hating on him
you know we might as well support him so
he can
maybe be an example to other children so
they can see
where not to go wrong jemima walker
sky news
well this is sky news breakfast let's
have a look at the weather for you now
with kirsty
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning cool and changeable outlook
continues with sunny spells and
scattered showers again some will be
heavy and thundery already some rumbles
of thunder today
across parts of northwest england parts
of wales as well and down towards the
southwest we've got some bands of
showers here
otherwise for maybe it is a dry start to
the day a few missed and fog patches
lifting quite quickly
and in the far north of scotland in the
northern isles a weak weather front here
will bring some rain
and drizzle and that will move
southwards into the mainland through the
day
sunshine and showers developing pretty
widely yet again in the south east where
we'll see some of the heavier more
thundery downpours with the risk of hail
quite slow moving as well the showers
easing into the evening to leave another
largely dry and chilly night
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
kirsty thank you still to come on sky
news breakfast labor are calling for the
government to do more
to help homeowners whose property has
unsafe cladding we'll talk to the shadow
housing secretary
in a few minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
we should protect our heritage
unfortunately it will become part of
azerbaijan
this monastery is under the protection
for now the next five years at least of
russian peacekeepers
i'm diana magni and i'm sky's russia
correspondent based here in moscow
i witnessed the despair of the armenians
in nagorno-karabakh who were digging up
the soil of their dead relatives
it's armenians who've abandoned these
villages now
despite what their strategy is i'm not
sure but they have made
some arrests already today
they can't kill everyone they can't
shoot everyone they they can't arrest
everybody
[Music]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
[Music]
i mean this clearly says i love hitler
are you saying that
doesn't say hitler
[Music]
russia insists that its military buildup
in the arctic is purely defensive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well breaking news this morning and the
environment secretary george eustis has
just confirmed there
may be a delay to the next season of
lockdown restrictions it follows
concerns
over rising levels of infection from the
indian variant of coronavirus
a few minutes ago mr eustis told us the
government had to remain cautious
and flexible when it comes to the
current plan to relax the rules
next month we want it to go ahead uh
there's a whole plan
about it of course but we cannot rule
anything out and and that is why the
prime minister said we will take this a
step at a time
as we uh have one set of easements and
just yesterday we've had a further set
of easements opened
more parts of the economy we need to see
how that beds down over the next uh two
to three weeks
and then shortly before the 21st of june
we'll be in a position to assess
whether we can go to that next stage we
want to do that that's always been the
plan
we want each step to be an irreversible
step but we can never rule out that
there may have to be a delay
let's talk to our political
correspondent kate mccann i mean that's
the key thing isn't it not ruling
anything out at this stage
yeah and i think when he was talking to
you you got a real sense didn't you
about what the government is going to do
over the next couple of weeks after
we've seen the unlocking this week
the plan really is to watch and wait and
to look at the data to see how it's
being affected by this indian variant
and then to make that decision i thought
it was fascinating actually
that he basically said to you that the
decision on june 21st
could come really quite close to that
date we may not get very much notice at
all
and perhaps that's to be expected
because well those rates of the indian
variant are quite low case numbers are
still quite low and it's important to
remember that so people don't
get too overly worried the the concern
is about what the vaccine is going to do
how it's going to react
and whether it's going to hold up and be
protective against this variant which we
now know is dominant in at least two
areas of the country
and spreading into others there was
another portion of that interview that
was
really interesting when george justice
was talking about local lock downs
though now we know that that in
government is something that they would
really like to avoid
but he said to you that it's something
that they won't rule out it is a
potential that is being looked at as a
contingency plan not just pushing that
june 21st date back
but possibly making local areas stick to
different rules if they have higher
rates of this indian variant and i
suppose that's what we're going to see
over the next couple of weeks
is the discussion move to how we can
potentially stop that spread
and what that might mean for all of us
going forward okay kate thank you
well labour is warning that lives and
livelihoods could be at risk if the
government doesn't do more
to help homeowners whose property has
unsafe cladding they say developers
should be given a deadline
to remove all combustible material all
of this of course in the wake of
the tragedy at grenfell of course let's
talk to the shadow secretary of state
for housing
lucy powell good to see you this morning
look what exactly do you want to see
happen here
well we're going to be calling a vote in
parliament today
an amendment to the queen's speech uh
calling on the government to act
uh to save lives and livelihoods we want
to see
a deadline now put in place because
there's just not been the
urgency about this situation so we want
to see a deadline of june
2022 for all dangerous cladding and
other materials to be removed from the
outside
of buildings that would be five years
since the grand fell
tragedy and we also want to see uh
enshrined in legislation protection for
leaseholders
and others other residents from having
to pay the cost
of this remediation work and removing
the dangerous client the government
decided not to enshrine that in
legislation despite a number of votes
in the house of commons in recent weeks
and now really is the time
for them to to make absolutely clear
that that isn't going to be the case and
just two weeks ago we had a terrible
fire
in the new providence wharf in east
london
that was covered in the dane saying
dangerous cladding
that grenfell tower was covered in and
really this should now be
a real wake-up call for the government
that it's got to act with a much greater
sense of urgency
yeah i mean there is a lot a real
problem isn't that that people
are now sort of own houses that are
unsellable
so that they're stuck in their
accommodation but the costs for this are
absolutely huge aren't they i mean who's
going to pay for it
well the costs are large at the moment i
mean one of the issues is we don't know
to what extent the costs are because the
government has not in this whole last
four years
actually undertaken a full nationwide
audit
of which buildings are most at risk
with with what kind of remediation work
that is necessary
so we aren't sure what the cost really
are the government have recently
increased
the uh building safety fund to five
billion pounds and
we welcome that but there are lots of
issues with that fund in terms of the
scope the timetable
and it's being done on a first come
first served uh
basis but actually you know what the
government should be doing
is uh is doing this full audit of every
building like they did in australia
and other places and then what they
should be doing is also going after
the developers and the building owners
to pay the cost of this remediation work
so it doesn't all fall
on on the taxpayer but we're also
calling for a national task force on
this area because the whole system as
you say is now broken
people can't insure can't sell their
properties
the whole system of risk assessment of
regulation
of oversight is broken and it isn't
working and the government has to leave
that process
by bringing together a task force of all
the players
to let's fix this market so that people
who've done the right thing
in buying their own home and now through
no fault of their own
are finding themselves on the verge of
bankruptcy and the government have got
to act
can i ask you about coronavirus i mean
you're a northwest mp
and obviously a lot of the concern over
the indian variant
is happening in the northwest what
should happen
now do we delay the 21st of june
potentially do we
stick to that and locally lock down
areas that are badly affected do we
vaccinate everybody in those areas what
would your plan be for your constituents
well as you say there are some worrying
trends with this
uh new variant that it does seem to be
transmitting more quickly than previous
variant
as you say it's still relatively uh
small
amounts across the country but in some
places
it's very uh spreading quite quickly
now indeed i think it's too early to say
about what should happen
in june but what we have been calling
for here in greater manchester
and nationally is that we really do
motor on
with some surge vaccinations as well as
uh surge testing focusing on places like
bolton
and blackburn where the indian variant
is
is now significantly on the rise and the
government
are always i'm afraid a little bit slow
to act on these issues
and we are really concerned about the
timing of the
of india going on on the red list in the
first place so
i think we would all especially those of
us in greater manchester
we would all be very reluctant and wary
to go down a road of local lockdowns um
they didn't really work
at last time but they became incredibly
difficult and divisive for those areas
that were
put in early lockdown and poor old
bolton and blackburn
you know have really been at the at the
forefront of this
for the last year so i think you know
let's get that surge vaccination surge
testing
capacity in very very quickly into these
areas
and hopefully uh we'll be able to to see
some of this off
okay lucy powell good to talk to you
thank you
now police in gloucester investigating
the disappearance of a woman thought to
have been killed by
fred west say there's enough evidence to
start
excavating a cafe in the city let's
talk to our correspondent dan whitehead
who joins us now bring us up to date dan
yeah we had a statement last night from
gloucestershire police who've been
outside the clean plate cafe here in the
center of gloucester confirming that
they are
now going to be starting excavation work
it's after their
forensic archaeologists confirm that
they have found over the last week
as they've been assessing the cellar of
this cafe structural
anomalies and they will now work to
establish whether there are
human rape remains this all links to the
disappearance of 15 year old mary
bastone
who went missing back in 1968 she was
working a shift here at the age of 15 at
the
cafe under a different name then and
went missing
uh when waiting for a bus nearby
her disappearance has long been linked
to the serial killer fred west
who of course was charged with 12
murders of young women
between the 60s and 80s he committed
suicide
while pending trial back in 1995
now this all came to light around a week
or so ago after a production company
which was filming a tv
documentary on the case here at the cafe
had discovered some evidence that
evidence we now know
included some blue material now
mary was wearing a blue coat as she left
the cafe on the day that she disappeared
the police were called in after these
findings by the tv production company
this tent has been in place outside the
cafe since then and clearly now
they believe they have sufficient
evidence
to warrant excavation work now they say
that that is not going to start until
this wednesday at the very earliest
and that it will last several weeks this
of course is painstaking work
and the disappearance of mary is more
than 50 years ago now
so exactly what remains will be found if
any
remains to be seen there are newspaper
reports this morning that human bones
or what thought were human bones were
discovered by the production company
that has been
denied by uh the police just uh to bring
you as well a statement that we have had
uh from mary's family on this uh update
they say
that we are extremely happy
gloucestershire constabulary is
continuing to try and search for mary
and gives us a chance to potentially put
her at rest after all these years
we hope this is a chance to finally get
closure for mary
and would like to continue to ask for
privacy whilst the excavation is ongoing
that excavation
will start we understand later this week
okay
dad thank you now the government plans
to treble
tree planting rates in england to reach
7 000
hectares of new woodland a year as part
of efforts to tackle the climate crisis
it's going to offer multi-million pound
tree planting grants to provide
more incentives for landowners and
farmers
becky cottrell reports
these young trees are set to become a
vital part of this farm's ecosystem
small willow saplings are being planted
not in a wood
but in a vegetable field this
is agroforestry we all know that trees
capture carbon
but they're also a massive tool for
farmers they can provide you
extra crops above your vegetable crops
such as apples and pears and things like
that like we do here
but they can also they provide wind
protection for my crops
these trees don't just capture emissions
they also attract
songbirds that get rid of the insects
that attack the crops
meaning there's no need for chemical
pesticides so planting here
is efficient sustainable and it makes
financial sense
the government is offering agroforestry
grants but farmers already using this
technique
say funds have to be managed in the
right way
it's not about planting as many trees as
possible
50 really well planted trees really well
looked after for the first five years of
their life
are just as good as a hundred trees
really badly planted
but the government does want to talk
numbers they aim to plant
three times as many trees in england by
2024
creating 7 000 hectares of new woodland
every year across the uk we need to
plant
30 000 hectares annually over the next
three years
to help us reach net zero emissions by
but the woodland trust says demand for
housing is undermining green initiatives
we can actually see mature trees cut
down for new homes
and then people come along and say how
can we introduce more greenery to this
site
and that's been a huge missed
opportunity there and obviously keeping
mature trees delivers a much better game
than planting small ones which will take
decades to deliver
government campaigners and many
landowners say
farms need to be used to reduce
emissions
but growers like andy worry food
production will be driven abroad
to meet planting targets at home unless
farmers are given the support he says
they need to help us become carbon
neutral
becky cottrell sky news gloucestershire
and just to remind you watch the sky
news daily climate show
at half past six and half past nine
every weekday here on sky news
now still to come for you this morning
what is the best way to make sure that
covid vaccines reach those
most in need around the world try to
find out for you in a couple of minutes
really what we're saying in this paper
is at the same time
we should be making sure that we're
keeping vaccination production going
so that we can vaccinate those parts of
the world that
present don't have access to vaccines
they urgently need them and it's in our
own interests that they do get
vaccinated
because the biggest problem we now have
is that even if we do everything
which we are doing now to vaccinate our
own people
if you get variants new um types of
covert disease that arise in different
parts of the world the risk is that they
then come back into our own country and
you can see this obviously with the
indian variant now so the important
thing is at the same time as we're
vaccinating
our own people what we do is we've set
out a plan a detailed plan for the
international community
to make sure we're maximizing production
and distribution
to all parts of the world at least so
that in those parts of the world that
are the poorest
and where they don't have enough vaccine
at present we vaccinate at least the
most vulnerable
the key workers and the big urban
populations because that will stop the
spread of the virus
to other parts of the world the
governments are the only ones that can
coordinate
how you increase the vaccination
production so for example
it's important to make sure that some of
the
the production of vaccine at the moment
has been vaccine being produced for
other types of condition
that we're repurposing some of that and
that really requires government to help
negotiate that with the big
pharma companies so that you can
increase the amount of covert vaccine
and get it distributed you also need
government because
for example at the moment in africa
you've got about 1.2 billion people
you've got roughly i'm afraid at the
moment just over 30 million
doses of vaccine delivered for the
entire continent we need to make sure
that we're getting more
vaccine to the african continent by
maximizing
the supply of vaccine but the additional
problem you have
is that of that over 30 million
only a small part of it has yet been
actually
used for the population so you also need
to work with governments so that they're
able to absorb the vaccine
they're being given and vaccinate their
population effectively
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast but wherever you
are welcome to
safety rage what's the day podcast for
the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know symptoms of hay
fever can develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
for many places it's a cool and
changeable outlook of sunny spells and
scattered showers a largely dry start
but we have got thicker cloud in the far
north of scotland being some light rain
here
and elsewhere the showers will develop
through the day some of them could be
heavy and
thundery temperatures will be around the
mid teens most of the showers will begin
to fade
as we head into the evening now we've
got tree pollen at the moment
low to moderate across the uk and
ireland low levels for wales and
northeast scotland elsewhere levels
rising to moderate
it's birch ash and oak for many with
some
plane in the cities and the spores will
increase temporarily
after the rain the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
now committee of mps today begins
investigating the best way to ensure the
world's poorest people get vaccinated
against kovid 19 well someone who's
going to be giving evidence
today is heidi chow who's senior
campaigns and policy manager
at global justice now good to see you
look i mean what does a country like the
uk need to do in your opinion
good morning stephen yeah i think that
the uk
needs to support um the
the suspension of patents at the world
trade organization
what we're seeing right now is a
grotesque level of inequality around
vaccine access and so 82
of global vaccinations have been
administered in high-income countries
like the uk
but only 0.2 of global vaccinations
have taken place in low-income countries
and the reason why this is is because
essentially we are facing a supply
problem
a supply problem that's been created
because of pharmaceutical monopolies
and so only astral xenophobic can make
astrazeneca vaccine
only fires that can make the fisa
vaccine and these monopolies are
sustained by
intellectual property rules such as
patents but also through companies
guarding their know-how and their
technology
i mean a lot of these companies not all
but i mean
certainly astrazeneca has has provided
the vaccine at
cost to some countries hasn't it
yeah so ash zenica has um offered a
price pledge of
nonprofit pricing to countries and in
the in the global south
however we've noticed that this price
pledge
um has several holes in it so first of
all we've noticed that some lower in and
middle
income countries have actually paid
several times higher than the eu
price of the vaccine um and also that
we've discovered that there has been
there's an expiry date on this price
pledge and so they can withdraw this
price pledge
as soon as they determine when that then
the pandemic is over
and according to reports that could be
as soon as july 2021
and actually the price is just one issue
actually the main issue as i mentioned
is that we are facing a restriction of
supply because we have these
pharmaceutical monopolies in place and
actually if you're in a pandemic
we sort of need the opposite of um
monopolies instead of restricting
supplies we should be enabling
as many manufacturers as possible across
the world
to be making these vaccines and ramping
up production so there are enough
doses for all countries i mean are there
enough facilities to start producing
a generic version then of these vaccines
yeah so we've had we've heard widely
have heard reports of vaccine
manufacturers
in countries like bangladesh canada
south africa
denmark who are all standing ready to
help produce the vaccines
and actually they're saying to
pharmaceutical corporations that hold
the patents
they're saying please let us help make
these vaccines to help in the global
effort to ramp up production
because at the moment there just simply
are not enough doses to go around and
what we've seen is
high income countries like the uk like
the eu
us like the eu who've actually hoarded
doses in advance
and so actually what limited supplies
there are
they've been swooped up by high-income
countries
can i ask about business profits i mean
it's a it's
it's a difficult issue at times when
something like this is going on you sort
of think well
you just need to forget about all of
that the problem is these these big
pharmaceuticals spend
billions on research and development so
they can't be expected just to give
everything away can they
well actually the um six front runner
vaccines that we're seeing
are actually have actually been largely
funded by public funding
they've had about around the tune of 10
billion
um committed to their research and
development and actually in global terms
we've seen over 100 billion dollars go
into the
research and development of covert 19
vaccines and treatments
um and so there's a really strong
argument that actually these are already
people's vaccines
that actually these have been funded r d
have been funded by
um the public um the public have funded
the clinical trials and have under these
vaccines being tested on members of the
public
um governments have funded at-risk
manufacturing
um and even pharmaceutical corporations
have negotiated
liability indemnity with certain
governments and so actually
the public sector has had a massive role
in the research and development and
bringing these
vaccines to market heidi really good to
talk to you thank you
thank you
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's another cool and
changeable day with sunny smells and
scattered showers some of which will be
heavy and
thundery just like the past few days
this morning though for most it's a dry
start already the showers gathering in
parts of southwest england northwest
england
and some rain and drizzle coming to the
very far north of scotland and the
northern isles
otherwise the showers developing as the
day gets going some of them heavy and
slow-moving could merge to longer spells
of rain
and the greatest risk of hail and
thunder always towards the south
top temperatures into the mid teens the
showers easing as we go through the
evening will may linger for a time in
the east
and then a bit of a chilly night to come
where we have clear spells a bit more
rain across central northern scotland
tomorrow
and showers developing elsewhere
the weather sponsored by qatar airways